it has been nine months since Lincoln
Park frontman Chester Bennington shocked
the music world when he took his own
life leaving behind his wife to Linda
and six children and now after grieving
privately his friend and former Linkin
Park collaborator Mike Shinoda is
sharing his grief publicly he's
releasing a new album called
post-traumatic about his journey from
the ultimate darkness to finally finding
the life listening to some of the songs
already they feel it feel really wrong
it started in a really dark place in the
beginning I wasn't leaving my house it
felt very claustrophobic
you know having lost my one of my
closest friends and collaborators and my
you know we associate like who we are
with to some degree like what we do
right and so I felt very lost and how
did you find that voice the experience
of this last year has been crazy and I
wanted to put it into music not only to
just like put my foot put like a stamp
on it and say this happened but also to
allow the fans and the and the people
who have been along for the ride to
guide them on that journey and say you
know in terms of keeping up with my
narrative or understanding where I'm at
[Music]
how difficult was the emotional process
of actually making the music and writing
those kind of writing those kinds of
songs well I mean that life was
difficult music was easy like the music
made things easier we started talking
about what about mental health like do
you want to get involved with for
example like suicide prevention you want
to get involved with organizations that
deal with depression and so on you know
even in addiction and I thought number
one some of those things I just don't
have very much experience with like
you'd think I do
because one of my best friends dealt
with them but I don't personally suffer
from those things and those
conversations I think that the most
powerful thing that I can do for people
is to actually take the things that I've
learned and share them with people so
for example with mental health I've
learned that mental health we treat it
like physical we should treat it like
physical health so if you say I'm
feeling unhealthy you could wake up you
say I'm feeling sick then what would you
do you'd stay home from work you might
take medication and if it's really bad
you might say oh I need to go see a
doctor this is really bad but we don't
for some reason we don't do that when it
comes to mental health is that maybe the
hardest part to deal with in this whole
thing I think like as human beings when
we see an ailment we're like oh are you
okay exactly yeah yeah yeah sometimes
you have to just feel sad and you have
to just wait until it kind of stops
happening right I had terrible days and
now I have less bad days and eventually
you know we'll file find a new normal
like a new stasis and that that is the
journey that I'm on that you know in
this album you'll see it happening as I
go out and start touring and talking to
fans and doing different conversations
and different people it'll evolve
[Music]
will you perform all the song speaking
about tour are the songs that maybe you
won't perform at first because you're
not ready to that's a great question I
actually thought about I had that on
that question in my head they become too
hard to play then I'll take them out but
I'm going to start by really going for
it and facing it head-on and seeing what
happens because what I realized at one
point in this whole thing is I was a
little bit apprehensive about meeting up
with large groups of fans because I knew
that a lot of them would be crying and
saying I'm sorry and ask me why what
happened and I was scared of that until
I did it and then I realized what a
cathartic experience it was for them and
myself